We'd like to examine the
motion of two particles.
Here's particle 1.
And here's particle 2.
And each particle
can have some motion.
In between them is
the center of mass.
And what we'd like
to do is figure out
how to describe the motion
of each of these particles
with respect to
the center of mass.
So let's choose some
coordinate system.
Origin down here.
Here's our particle r1.
Here's our particle r2.
And here is our center of mass.
Now in the reference frame
of the center of mass,
we have position
vector r1 prime.
And we have position
vector r2 prime.
And what we'd like to
do is find expressions
for r2 prime and
r2 prime in terms
of the positions of r1 and r2.
Now we call that the position of
the center of mass for this two
body problem is given by
m2 m1 r1 plus m2 r2 divided
by the total mass.
And here we use
the vector triangle
that r1 prime equals r1
minus center of mass.
Now remember this vector
is equal to this vector
minus that vector.
Sometimes people like
to say the vector
r1 is equal to r plus r prime.
And that's how we get
that relationship.
Now we can use our
result here that r1 prime
is r1 minus m1 r1 plus m2
r2 divided by m1 plus m2.
And when we combine
terms-- let's just do this
so you can see it-- r1
minus m1 r1 plus m2 r2
divided by the total mass.
We now have the m1
r1 terms cancel.
And we have a common m2 over
m1 plus m2 times r1 minus r2.
Now r1 minus r2 is a vector
that goes from-- here is r1.
Here's r2.
So the vector r1 minus r2
is the relative position
of vector 1 with respect to 2.
And let's give that
a special name.
We'll call that r1, 2, the
relative position vector.
So we have m2 over m1
plus m2 r1, 2 is r1 prime.
Now you can easily see
that if you interchange
the indices 1 and 2, the
only thing that changes here
is a sign.
And if we interchange 1 and
2-- and this is an exercise
that you can do--
then r2 prime is minus
m1-- I'm interchanging
the indices.
The minus sign came from
the interchange of 1 and 2.
And so we get m1 over m1 plus
m2 with the minus sign r1, 2.
Now what is the
significance of this result?
If you know the
position of r1 and r2,
you know the relative velocity.
If you have information
about this relative position,
if you know the relative
position vector,
then you can separately get the
locations of the two objects
in the center of mass frame.
Now this quantity in
here will appear often.
And I'd like to introduce
a new quantity called
the reduced mass.
And that reduced mass,
mu, is the product
of m1 m2 over m1 plus m2.
It's a simple exercise to see
that 1 over mu is 1 over m1
plus 1 over m2.
And we'll encounter
that a little bit later.
Then I can write both
of these vectors--
and this is our conclusion--
that r1 prime is the reduced
mass.
Notice we have an m2 here, so
we have to divide by m1 times
the vector r1, 2.
And r2 prime is minus
the reduced mass.
Again, we now have
to divide by m2.
And you see this nice symmetry
of m1 and 1, 2 and 2, r1, 2.
And that's our key result.